i'm not a fussy actor i'm not a
difficult actor i can always get i can
always find it i can always do it but i
was i found it so difficult i couldn't
actually couldn't act
and i
i sort of fell apart a bit just looking
at that clip reel and think about all of
your characters one of the things that
strikes me about part of the power of
them is the secrets that they either
choose to share or that they choose to
keep to themselves i'm wondering as
you're building a performance is it just
as crucial to think about what you will
kind of show to the audience that's just
what you're going to be holding back
yeah i've always thought of characters
in some respects like a sort of advent
calendar which you'd have here don't you
um with all those little closed windows
which you're allowed to open one every
day and see the life within a house
and i i i've
i i prefer
to do that to keep
to keep the audience looking forward to
the next moment where they might learn
something else or they might not
um after all we don't
most of us anyway wear our hearts on our
sleeves we keep things covered for those
who are very special
and
i think by doing that by having that
approach to to a performance um it
it makes the audience more interested
and
i think it's truer to life
what's your earliest memory of acting
when i was at prep school which
uh uh in england lasts from seven till
thirteen
um i played i think when i must have
been about 12
in a moore's mystery
um and i played a sort of agatha
christie type um
detective who was a lady
[Laughter]
and she wore tweeds it was a it was set
on the moors i remember
she wore a tweed suit
a rather nice
jacket and and and a skirt and um
and sensible shoes
and just before i went on
the um
the uh
the director the
mistress who was directing the play said
to me don't forget to adjust your shirt
your skirt before you sit down
or when you sit down
and
i'd seen the older boys and i was very
envious of them because we wore shorts
and i'd seen the older boys before they
sat down
hitching up their trousers
and they sat down i thought it was very
grown up
so every time
before
i sat down i hitched up my skirt
[Laughter]
and the audience laughed
and it was my first time of having a
wonderful drug of of doing something and
having the audience laugh
and that was the first thing i ever
remember my earliest memory of so many
of us uh could probably say the same of
seeing you was of course bright said
revisited 1981 which got your bath to
nomination i'm wondering it was an
incredibly successful and influential
mini-series i'm wondering about the
success in that how it did or maybe
didn't influence subsequent choices did
did you think about the next roles a
little differently after brideshead
no i i i chose to break well i put
myself up for brideshead because i was
doing um
theater in london
at the young vic and in the west end and
the royal shakespeare company
and i was seeing my name up in lights
which is very flattering but i knew that
no one was coming because i was in it
because nobody knew who i was
and i thought i have to address this
and i was trying to make films but
nobody wanted to cast me they were
casting an act called simon ward for all
the parts that i would have been right
for he played young churchill you might
remember
um it was much better looking than me
and had experience and so
what
rumbling of dissent i believe from the
ladies
were they wouldn't look at me and and so
a friend of mine george howard um came
to see a play i was doing in greenwich
and we were having a drink afterwards
and he said have you ever read said
revisited and i said no
he said well you read it's great book
and granada film it he knew about it
because they wanted to use his house
castle howard
um
and he said read the book and you know
so i read the book and and got in touch
with granada and said if you're going to
make this i'd love to be involved and
they said we haven't got a direct yet or
anything but we'll be in touch and they
were
and they asked me to play sebastian
and i said no by then i'd fallen in love
with charles who i thought was the
quintessential englishman and i thought
i could play him
better than any other actor i could
think of whereas i could think of a lot
of actors who could play sebastian i was
i just
i i felt charles needed an actor who
would be self-effacing uh like if you
throw a great party
what you have to do is to make sure that
everybody else has a great time not that
you have a great time
and um
charles actually required almost no
acting
and it wasn't until about the fourth
month that i started doing something and
the director said what are you doing i
said well i thought i'd do this he said
just don't do anything
you don't need to do anything
and
so we made that and there was a
complication because there was a strike
and i had already
committed to carol rice and said that if
you can
persuade hollywood to let this unknown
englishman play in your film i'll be
there
um
and i said but i suspect you're going to
need a star
well he called me in the middle of
bride's head and said
i don't need a star i've got meryl
streep you can play it
um
so
so i said great
but then there was a striker bryce and
so there was there was difficulty in
dates and in effect in in as it turned
out i made both at the same time
um i we had a layoff from bride's head
of four months well i went away and did
uh the french lieutenant's woman and and
then had a break in the middle of the
french tennis room because i had to go
back we had booked oxford hartford
college to do the oxford stuff and that
couldn't be shifted
so i had to leave francis and his woman
go back and be charles at oxford and
they go back to lime regis to do the
french tennis woman
and
they both came out at much the same time
friendship i was sticking on all the
time i was sticking on bits of facial
hair and tearing them off because
charles had
sideburns and and
sue baradel who um
who did the makeup was was wonderful she
didn't just stick them on she laid them
on hair by hair by hair
it took hours
and i remember when we did the test
for them we were in my house in
hampstead in london and harold pinter
was there because he'd written the
script for the french tennis room and
then his wife lady antonio fraser was
also there and and she's one hell of a
woman and she came up to me at one point
when they were on and she looked at it
and she said oh that's so good did they
take the hair from other parts of your
body
[Laughter]
talked about secret keepers a couple of
moments ago which brings to mind damage
and water land and m butterfly lolita
all amazing performances i'm wondering
it must be something my wife's in
waterline she's terribly good does
anyone see in waterland
yeah
he plays my wife in it
god that was hard
[Laughter]
it no seriously it was um she she joined
the film quite late
because i think miranda richardson was
originally going to play it and miranda
dropped out you had to go and do
something else and so
chane was cast and the director stephen
gyllenhaal
um jake gyllenhaal's dad
stephen said well i want you to stay in
separate hotels
um i said that's fine
so so
so we did but we the first scene we had
to do was when i discovered her but
those of you who haven't seen the film
this is boring but see it because it's
actually good quite good um it was when
i discovered here in the bathroom
and she's just given this child back
and
she's completely distraught
and i'm her husband
and i found it so emotionally and i'm
not a fussy actor i'm not a difficult
actor i can always get i can always find
it i can always do it but i was i found
it so difficult i couldn't actually
couldn't act
and i
i sort of fell apart a bit
and stephen eventually said come on
let's go home
and we went home and we came in the next
day but it was just
you know when you're playing with your
wife you have so much uh baggage there
anyway so much stuff you know
and so what we were trying to do by
staying in separate hotels was to
separate
that from
but it's so he can't do it like that
and um and when i saw her in that
absolute distress
uh oh
i just stopped me acting i couldn't do
it couldn't do it went home it was all
right the next day yeah it's a terrific
but anyway we were talking about secrets
and it must be such a gift as a as an
actor to have a character as all four of
those terrific films are for you that
that you know something about yourself
that the audience won't find out until
that final act or those final scenes it
must be such a such a treat and a gift
to have characters like to really sink
your teeth into right
it's funny how many actors don't i mean
i was we're doing a scene the other day
i was shooting a film in kentucky and um
i i i wasn't doing it was two young
things in it and i went and looked at
this and i
i said to them why are you behaving like
that
somebody knocked at the door that's
right they were sitting in a motel some
are not in the door it's great they just
made love
and i said it could be room service it
could be me my character who's had a
place to sort of two doors down in the
motel it could be anybody you don't have
to creep in fact it was somebody a big
surprise for them and
and things were going to really start
moving once that person came into the
room but they didn't know that and i
said you you only know what you know at
that moment play that don't play the
script that will happen later
um
you know play play the supr play moment
to moment to moment than the reality of
that and and they changed and it was a
lot better the scene i have to say you
know he went to the door like a normal
person
instead of going to the person who was a
door as if there was he was going to see
dracula on the other side of it
so secrets yeah it's great to have
secrets as a gary it's great to to carry
secrets i mean i love enigmas i
i know a lot of people and i know none
of them completely
they're they always however
i mean i love getting to know people
that's why i love deep relationships and
the joy of that is is that it's
unpeeling is getting to know them
getting to know them more and more and
more
um
but
but but they always part of them remains
an enigma part of everybody else to me
is an enigma and therefore i try to play
characters
that have that energy
enigmatic quality i i just think it's
sort of real to life
um and and great writers of course
provide that
and not only enigma but inconsistency
was another thing i love in characters
shakespeare's brilliance at
people behave inconsistently we all do
and and a lot of poor writers write
consistent characters and say things
like oh he wouldn't do that and actors i
sometimes hear in rehearsal say oh he
wouldn't do that and you think what do
you mean he wouldn't do that people do
anything
you know and if he does that then that
makes him a slightly different person
because he's done that
so
the line through a character needn't be
smooth it's jagged
we all behave oddly at times find the
reason find the reasons
[Music]
[Music]
you